oh my goodness
Olivia congratulations congratulations
to you all on the link incredible movie
um take us back because this movie
actually well the script was on The
Blacklist
how did it come your way and so the
journey I first of all thank you all so
much for coming you could be anywhere
and you came to see this and I'm very
very grateful I'm very honored to be on
this panel with these two
um yeah don't worry darling was
originally a spec written by Shane and
Carrie Van Dyke it was on The Blacklist
and in 2018. I saw
um the log line and I thought it was so
interesting and I thought I wonder if we
take this idea of a woman who believes
she's living in the 1950s realizes she's
in a simulation what if we took that and
kind of told the story through a female
lens and uh so it was a piece of
material that we kind of took Katie
Silverman my amazing producing partner
and screenwriter we took it and and just
kind of reinvented it through what we
felt was very much a personal quest to
answer some burning questions we had
about kind of the complexity of
complicity when it comes to kind of the
patriarchy and it was it was a really
fun process of reimagining something
that we thought was a very compelling
original idea
and we'll talk about the timing later on
but talk about the costing because how
do you find the perfect Alice and Jack
and you know those two characters go on
this journey
yeah well you know something that was
very clear to all of us who made the
film was that it all rested of course on
Alice's shoulders and she is
um my idea of a modern superhero she is
the very rare kind of revolutionary who
is willing to sacrifice
all the comfort of her of her Bubble
World to to kind of destroy the system
that very much serves her and I think
that's really rare in in history and I
think we wanted to find someone who
could feel like they had that level of
capability of intensity of Courage but
also was incredibly human and organic
within a world that we didn't want you
to feel the inauthenticity of we wanted
you to feel this was very current even
though it was period you know we all
wanted it to feel very
um yeah organic in in every single way
and Florence Pugh just has a magnetism
and a Humanity
as well as a sense of humor and uh
intelligence that is innate it can't be
faked and that was clearly what we
needed for Alice and you know the movie
is also really a love story in a very
admittedly Twisted way but we wanted
them as a couple to feel
um unique within this world we wanted
the audience to immediately feel like
well there's something modern about them
they're their passion their their
connection feels so real and and not
um stereotypically sort of 50s in the
way that people often perceive those
relationships from that era to be
um and so it was about finding the
perfect complement of Florence's
intensity and Harry had that innate
warmth and charm as well and together
they just made our ideal Allison Jack
and Visually the film is beautiful
marilabatic cinematography at Katie
Byron's production design and Ariana
costumes I mean give it up for Ariane
you did such an amazing job I mean talk
about
working with Olivia and building Alice
and this character through costume
well from the get-go meeting Olivia
meeting you
um it was very clear I was sent the
script which was
in uh for the same it was it was very
intriguing and it was
um telling the story that I felt we
hadn't seen before and the idea that a
woman was directing it and I was a fan
of Olivia's work as an actor and then I
had seen book smart and was really Blown
Away by it so I was so surprised when I
read the script I didn't know what um
she would be making next and I was a
very seen as we didn't know each other I
was very intrigued to see to understand
I knew of your activism and and you know
I I admire that about you and I loved
that it was going to be your vision and
then you sent me it's weird to talk
about her with her sitting here so I
have to talk to her and then um then she
sent me her mood board which was uh
filled with beautiful and very
sophisticated images that were more art
based than anything and it was like a
beautiful
um
uh visual timeline and and Narrative of
how she you know was envisioning the
story and I thought immediately that
um this was going to be a conversation
at a high level which is really
important to me and um and then we met
and it was like
um really exciting because I felt that
you know it's a different I've worked
with
um a couple actors who have directed and
it's really a a special experience for a
costume designer because they
intrinsically understand how a costume
can help not only their performance but
tell the story so there is an intimate
understanding of character development
through costume design with the director
who's an actor so
um that is um I love collaborating with
directors obviously that's like my first
thing and then a director is an actor
it's like another layer of
conversation at a deeper level a lot of
directors don't have the vernacular for
costumes or and it can be quite
intimidating so that was exciting I just
felt that you know from the first time
we met so did I answer your question I
went on a tangent but totally so um so
that was really like the impetus also I
have done a few films set in this
similar time period And I felt like this
was an opportunity
of course to uh not be so true to the
period as it's revealed as the story is
revealed and um you know there is this
um Orthodoxy to costume design sometimes
with period pieces where we can get very
stuck on what what was and the freedom
to create our own world
um With Victory and to be able to kind
of as I said plant Easter eggs for the
reveal was really really exciting to me
funds that talk about your
the conversations that you had with
Olivia about getting to the reveal like
how much
you know back and forth did you have
over Zoom
um about how you were going to reveal
what's actually happening
I mean
we just had to experiment I mean for us
when I started when I came in there was
already like a moving place but we
wanted to just Elevate as much as we we
could and for us the litmus test was the
the Durant scene so eight people around
the table like how do you create tension
and you stay on the attention and
everybody's involved it's like the other
thing is you you can figure out or or
action scenes you there there's it
becomes mechanical I mean it's fun but
that scene was always for us if this
scene works that scene that was sort of
the goal when when it came in Olivia
said that has to be the best scene of
the film so we work towards that uh
and the Revelation is that it's it's
really tricky because you want to give
something but how how long and what is
the the information you want to give
when you want to give so we have to
reorganize the thought process and just
uh create that we have to control I
think the thing with with editing is
just not just it's it's how do you
create
a pace that you the the audience is not
ahead of you you have to be you have to
guess so
if you become this this metronome if the
rhythm is just too safe then you lost
the audience but by controlling it by
giving a lot and then giving a little
not enough and also we had the element
of that there's a Sonic element and we
got to work with Skip and Paul we're
just incredible and that you fold into
the storytelling then just becomes this
I mean it's it's it's such a and you
have incredible performance such a gift
for an editor it was we had a ton of fun
and if you talk about landing on the
ending
well the ending was it was an ongoing
experiment I guess as it always is but
you know we really wanted to leave the
question open for the audience in terms
of what happened to Alice and I wanted
it to be optimistic I think when we
discovered we wanted it we knew the
sound we wanted the audience to make we
wanted it to feel emotionally like a gas
like an inhale and then we thought well
that kind of helped us find the rhythm
of the end if we were trying to get to
that sound
um and I have to give it up to the
studio who you know had every reason to
feel like this question should be
answered and this should be a more kind
of like a typical ending to a studio
film and we had really interesting
conversations about in film if the
audience has left wanting to know more
that's a good thing and and I think
often in studio filmmaking they think
well the audience was left unsatisfied
and of course there's this difference
between on dissatisfaction and just
curious velocity so that was kind of an
interesting experimental you know like
experiment and conversation to have with
a studio who in the end like really
supported me which I was very grateful
for but I I really wanted people to feel
um you know optimistic in that Alice has
has is free whether that means death
whether that means she's got out whether
you feel that it's a happier for life in
a modern day or not I've wanted it to be
something people argued about in parking
lots and over late night dinners
um
and people have been arguing so that's
that's a good thing
but it it was uh you know it was all a
testament to to the performances that we
felt like we had enough material to
continue experimenting in so many
different ways amazing Olivia Ariana
phoneza thank you so much and thank you
everybody thank you all so much thank
you so much
[Applause]